vsauce kevin here jennifer thompson
studied every detail of her attacker's
face as she was being sexually assaulted
at knifepoint his hairline broad
cheekbones a mustache that looked like a
pencil thin dirt smear
she couldn't fight back physically but
mentally she could memorize every little
detail and bring him to justice police
described jennifer as the best witness
they'd ever had her eyewitness testimony
convicted ronald cotton and he was
sentenced to life in prison plus 50
years despite no physical evidence
linking him to the crime there was no
evidence because he didn't do it and 11
years later dna testing proved it so
how could the best witness ever get it
completely wrong
why do about 70 percent of dna
exonerations in the us involve
eyewitness misidentification
and
how can what we've seen
turn into something
we never saw
i need you to point to the shape that
rolled over your foot on the evening of
march 14 2015.
okay this example seems stupid but it
shows one of the many many problems with
witness identification
only one shape in the lineup comes close
to the description of the suspect the
choice is obvious only a circle can roll
now this lineup requires an actual
identification of size and color but
here's a question how do you even get to
a lineup first you need a description
jennifer thompson studied pages of ears
chins and noses so police could
reconstruct her attacker's face using an
identicate in 1984 that was a sketch on
paper now the identicate is digital the
hand-drawn facial composite looked
nearly perfect to her now the police had
a picture of the suspect that could be
broadcast on the local news here's the
problem some witnesses are amazing their
autobiographical memory of an event is
flawless but
then there's the rest of us and hugo
munsterberg wrote the book on how what
we forget and what we don't know becomes
an illusion that replaces
reality in 1908 munsterberg published on
the witness stand a collection of
articles and essays about psychological
factors that affect trial outcomes
what's more persuasive than a witness
pointing to a defendant and swearing
they did it munsterburg insisted that
gold standard of evidence in a trial was
actually
really untrustworthy trials predate the
ancient greeks and while we've always
known witnesses could lie
only recently do we understand how easy
it is to think you're telling the truth
when your brain is just
wrong
munsterberg suggested that justice often
miscarry due to the treachery of human
memory and to prove it he pointed the
finger
at himself
he wasn't some academic pontificating on
criminal justice theory he was robbed
and as a witness he messed it all up it
went like this he testified under oath
that burglars entered his house through
a window they actually came in through
the cellar he said they left a clock
packed in paper it was wrapped in a
tablecloth
he gave a complete list of garments that
were stolen
it turns out they took seven more than
he said he claimed he found candle wax
on the second floor but the wax
drippings were actually in the attic
finally he reported two burglars but
maybe it was just one he had no way to
tell
munsterburg had given over 3 000
academic lectures and not once had to
use note cards his mind and memory were
amazing but he admitted that he'd rushed
into the house and surveyed it all
quickly noting after the fact that his
brain filled in the gaps for him
the burglar was eventually caught
breaking into another house and they
found monster berg's jacket in his
apartment but the fact is the world's
expert on witness reliability was almost
completely wrong he said i felt myself
somewhat alarmed in seeing how many
illusions had come in
so if the pioneer of witness reliability
scholarship couldn't overcome his
illusions
what chance did a college student
traumatized by a violent sexual assault
have
police presented jennifer thompson with
a photo lineup of six men they told her
that the suspect might not even be in
the lineup but she figured if he wasn't
there why would they bother
she recognized one of the photos and
chose ronald cotton with absolute
certainty a week later jennifer
recognized the same man in a physical
lineup to her the parts that didn't
match her memory made him even guiltier
like he'd changed his hair to purposely
deceive her
the photo lineup reinforced her mental
image of her attacker and anti-proof
became proof
police confirmed that she'd chosen the
same man in both lineups she said
it was him there was no doubt in my mind
did you feel absolutely certain
absolutely certain well what was said to
me afterwards was that's the same person
you picked out in the photo lineup
so in my mind i thought
bingo
i did it right how can the truth compete
with that
estimator variables are the parts of
eyewitness identification that police
can't control
so like cross-racial ids tend to be less
accurate than ids within a witness's
race
that isn't the police's fault people
think different things and they just
plain see different things from an
optical illusion to the colors of a
dress
but the real enemy of memory is time
herman ebbinghaus's forgetting curve
provides a visual representation of how
quickly your memory can erode and as
early as the 1880s his equation
expressed the vulnerability of memory
over time but forgetting over time is
only half the problem the other half is
teaching yourself the lie
every time you retell your story to
police to a lawyer to a journalist to a
friend you're essentially engaging in
the space repetition of practice you're
learning your memories get clearer
almost like memorizing lines for a play
so the longer it's been the more you
forget the more you forget the more you
invent the more you repeat the more
confident you are
whether it's true
or not
jennifer thompson said if there was a
death penalty i wanted ronald cotton to
get it i would pull the switch if they
let me
when she pointed her finger at cotton to
identify him during the trial she said
she wished it had been
a gun
ronald cotton had become her attacker in
her mind through unconscious
transference
but there was no physical evidence no
fingerprints no clothing no fibers from
the victim's apartment linking ronald
cotton to the crime
he maintained his innocence and refused
to entertain a plea bargain
he was convicted based largely on
jennifer's testimony
three years later jennifer thompson came
face to face with her actual attacker
and
didn't even notice ronald cotton was
given a new trial that's great right
wrong
this time he also faced charges for
another assault and burglary from that
same night
meanwhile he met a man in prison who
looked a lot like jennifer's original
composite sketch and he looked so
similar to ronald cotton that other
inmates couldn't tell them apart bobby
poole lived in the same town as ronald
and jennifer and he was currently
serving a sentence for sexual assault if
all that wasn't enough to raise
suspicions he'd literally confessed to
other inmates that he assaulted her
ronald's lawyers called bobby poole as a
witness in the new trial
poole denied everything jennifer
thompson had wanted to be the one to
personally execute ronald cotton but
when she was in the same courtroom as
her real attacker the man whose face
she'd studied
she didn't recognize him at all
ronald was convicted again
and sent back
to prison
richard rosen a professor at unc chapel
hill and lawyer tom lambeth took on
ronald's case they secured the dna
analysis that wasn't available in 1984.
ronald insisted that he'd be cleared and
the stakes were high a dna match would
cement his guilt
ronald wasn't lying
the tests showed that not only was
ronald innocent but that bobby poole was
the attacker
and over 10 years after first being
arrested
ronald cotton
was free
jennifer didn't dispute the dna findings
she knew she'd been proven wrong she
wasn't defensive about it she was
horrified
she said i had to tell people not only
was i a rape victim but a rape victim
with an extremely bad memory and someone
had to pay 11 years for that
i wondered how i could have been
so stupid
jennifer was
not stupid
during the attack she actually convinced
poole to get rid of his knife then
outwitted him by offering to get him a
drink and using the distraction to
escape
she just
fell prey to the vulnerabilities all
witnesses have and a few simple changes
can drastically improve witness
reliability
lineups that offer a range of similar
choices are most effective that way
suspects can't stand out and making
lineups sequential so one photo at a
time is compared to a witness's memory
instead of being compared to one another
is even more effective
police need to make it clear to
witnesses that the suspect might not be
there and the cops who make the lineup
shouldn't be the ones who administer it
that double-blind process ensures police
can't give any verbal or nonverbal cues
to the witness to influence their choice
recording the lineup solidifies the
record and police should ask witnesses
to detail their level of confidence in
their choice
but jennifer thompson would have said
100 percent
and advancing science was the only thing
that saved ronald cotton from a life in
prison
in my mind i was sure what i saw
[Music]
thinking back on it
i don't know that i would have done
anything different
jennifer and ronald are friends now he
never blamed her for being wrong
they've given talks together nationwide
their families are close and they even
end phone conversations by saying
love you
half the states in the u.s have
instituted some form of eyewitness
identification reform
but
can we make sure what happened to both
ronald cotton and jennifer thompson
never happens again
probably not
hugo munsterberg was right from
biological limitations to systematic
error the moment our eyes and ears
capture something
the truth
is vulnerable
we can get better but will never be
perfect
two thousand two hundred years ago the
roman playwright plata said that
one eyewitness is worth 10
ear witnesses
people attest to the truth by saying
they saw something with their own two
eyes
they'll tell you that something is so
good you need to see it to believe it
but the truth is
sometimes you need to believe it
to see it
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
you